a Copa hoje vou ensinar a fazer um
barquinho se move com a ajuda de um
pequeno motor elétrico que
vocês tem que botar uma folha ao meio
daquelas de impressora e depois gostaram
um pedacinho mais ou menos assim estas
duas partes nós vamos usar agora
mas guardo ele vai ser preciso e pronto
com explicadinho lá
o
dragão baixo e
E aí
a senhora comprar os lados e
é assim
o que tu já ensina a fazer isso aqui é
é quase igual ao filme diferente no
final tem que ser tratado
e para conseguir por Colé e pronto agora
e nos triângulos retângulos assim
o Ivan assim ó
E aí
[Música]
e
isso é uma carona
aqui diferença que eu estava a dizer é
um abraço fique por dentro
e depois conseguir colocar um leque
passo seguinte
furao com está falando com aquele menino
que é isto e depois fui direto frase é
só fazer isso me o que é
e quem tá o bracinho presentes no centro
feito barco impermeável
um sinal de coragem
é de Pina
se você encontrar vai ter um pouquinho
mais uma cópia não sei que já passaram
por irritar começar a fazer aqui Leme
Oi
para aqui
e fica altura mas não é assim
que eu fiz aquele furo na caixa
a cabeça para baixo não tem que estar
aqui passar
dentro d'água
eu não tenho
aqui
brincar de Educação do aqui
agora estou
E aí
e o que fazer
[Música]
e
pode ser feito agora fazer suporte para
o motor dele e
[Música]
E aí
a
segurar aqui escolher diz mais ou menos
fazer força comprar mesa
Olá eu sou teu comentário que a
superfície vai sair aqui que eu vou
por
motor elétrico
a trabalhar começar a juntar as peças e
[Música]
um
tapa no barquinho
[Música]
o
Centro de Saúde II
E aí
[Música]
o
consórcio tá aqui ó
nós estamos não bata em nada
até agora partindo ir pa da minha filha
o e ver para Claro para pegar tem que se
preocupar e vamos falar aqui melhor
motor mexendo sempre com fita-cola
perguntei aqui os cabos juntos a
fundamentação
tá tudo em paz né um toque especial
gostado e até o próximo vídeo
muito grande é